you probably think Huskies are a breed  of dog but you're wrong they're actually  the greatest college basketball teams in  the world  mystic doesn't mean having the quality  of magic it means an awesome aquarium  and seaport 95s on a number close to a  hundred it's the worst place to be stuck  in rush-hour traffic behind Massholes  link compounds is in a boring body of  water it's the name of the nation's  oldest continuously operating amusement  park dunx has nothing to do with  basketball it's where you go for  bomb-ass cough the sound is not a type  of noise it's a beautiful estuary that  covers 1320 square miles  whalers are not the people who hunt  whales they're the legendary ice hockey  team that left Hartford in 1997 but who  will hopefully return someday soon most  people think Connecticut is just a small  state in the Northeast but it's actually  the best place to grow up